after the day of drama
political fireworks call the roll
the committee vote on brett kavanaugh
passed but with a huge
caveat from swing vote republican
senator jeff
flake i think it would be
proper to delay the floor vote
for up to but not more than one week
in order to let the fbi
continue to do an investigation limited
in time and scope
uh to the current allegations that are
there
i just want to thank my friend and
colleague senator flake and thank you
uh for giving us the time today to have
a conversation
all right mr chairman because of the
two-hour rule we're adjourned
an abrupt end left senators on both
sides
reeling this was kind of a surprise to
all of us senator flake has expressed
including in his speech yesterday his
concern about the divide in this country
before this latest twist republicans
made it very clear
this was the last thing they wanted
senator graham if you believe that brett
kavanaugh did not do this then why not
call for an fbi investigation to prove
that
because ma'am the fbi is not going to do
anything different than what i just
listened to the guy
the fbi is not going to be able to go to
witness please first
who the three people named have come
forward
now republicans are backed into a corner
investigate
or lose the final confirmation vote
be a hero senator why now
why now why not wait the pressure has
been on jeff flake to use his influence
to upend kavanaugh's nomination
this moment may have prompted a change
of heart
so help you god for most of the day it
seemed like yesterday's emotional
testimony from dr blasey ford would have
no
impact on this process i believed he was
going to rape me
i tried to yell for help when i did
brett put his hand over my mouth to stop
me from yelling
both testimonies had the nation hooked
brett kavanaugh's angry indignant tone
contrasted dr blasi ford's
low-key obliging manner it was
captivating viewing even the president
was impressed i thought her testimony
was very compelling
and she looks like a very fine woman to
me very fine woman
dr blasey ford has become a national
hero for women across america
while brett kavanaugh still has a path
to the supreme court
these protesters goal of stopping him
has undoubtedly edged
a little closer amanda walker sky news
washington